somos empreendedores e modelamos uma
escultura social soma de curitiba e
curioso pensar que curitiba reconhecida
do mundo internacionalmente pelo
planejamento urbano pelo transporte
coletivo mas existe uma pesquisa e tem
lá registro dizendo que em 1890 foi lá
que chegou a primeira bicicleta no
brasil e lá também se logo se
desenvolveu um clube de ciclismo feito
por imigrantes
é isso que vai perceber que o economy
fácil exige mais bicicletas que carros
do mundo nos carros naquela cidade meses
mais bicicletas
um grupo de artistas da cidade chamado
interlux começou a praticar a cidade
jovens que colavam cartazes nem de skate
e bicicleta plantava árvores gravam
praças onde centenas baldios começar a
fazer ações de elogio esse veículo é
esses elogios logo vieram a questões de
a questionamento com o poder público
para saber quais eram as iniciativas que
a prefeitura está fazendo para
bicicletas
apesar de tanto falarem de bicicletas
sendo é nos órgãos públicos do instituto
de planejamento o grupo recebeu tomou
muitos cafés e recebeu muitos apenas
costas dizendo que tava tudo certo que o
projeto se logo eles vão ver soluções da
cidade os problemas que existiam é
passar dos meses e anos passar uma
gestão e nada foi feito
é o prefeito foi reeleito em 2007
posso dizer que foi um marco do
movimento cycle ativista uma revolução
cultural de bicicleta é quando
aproximadamente 40 ciclistas achar uma
rua pouco movimentada no centro da
cidade
o próximo centro e pintar uma faixa
pontilhada com o programa de bicicletas
após a espetacular pintura o ciclista
estava celebrando é esse feito quando a
guarda municipal chegou e perguntou o
que tinha feito
senha todos levantaram as mãos e eles
tiveram que escolher três mais exaltados
pra ir no carro da polícia até a
delegacia do invent responde por
escolher um creme dental é lá em
curitiba é crime ambiental no caso eles
foram enquadrados como na inflação de
pichação e pichação é em infração grave
então não dá pra resolver sua atuação
social ou cesta básica você leva multa
mesmo o uso filhos mil filhos para cada
ciclista não tínhamos dinheiro né
mas isso foi ótimo fantástico foi a
partir dali se é compreender o que
existe existe uma rede muito grande
eles tinham uma comunicação um eficiente
que as pessoas né
e foi assim que ela começou a entrar na
pauta da cidade à imprensa
gostou desta notícia começou a cobrir é
as mídias todas a disputa pela ponta da
língua da mídia é esse movimento começou
a crescer e se fortalecer e ganhar uma
periodicidade
então todo mês de setembro esse
movimento se encontrava e promover essa
interação na cidade através de
atividades culturais através de música
em cruzamentos no horário do rush é com
intervenções artísticas performance
jardinagem libertária que você ter um
relacionamento afetuoso com a cidade a
partir de uma planta e esse movimento
então ele ganhou um nome e continua a
ser esperado ano após ano é conhecido
como o festival art biss ibope
neste ano o festival está na sua 10ª
edição então nós vamos preparando o
terreno da cidade
já colhemos os frutos não existem muitas
bicicletas muitas pessoas estão sendo
incentivadas contaminadas né com a
possibilidade de escolher um dia e para
o trabalho para o centro de bicicleta
não não era bem no centro onde a gente
via que existia uma estrutura acolhedora
o ciclista convidativa para que ele
pudesse pedalar e usar é funcionalmente
a bicicleta foi aí que o fernando ele me
mostrou um portão entre dois prédios no
centro da cidade e ali tinha uma fresta
por onde você podia ver uma rampa
é esse aí essa rampa ela escolha de uma
rua na antiga rua da cidade chamada do
fogo
agora totalmente a rua são francisco mas
é uma rua que ligava a oeste do paraná
é lá essas rua é onde tem oposição mais
bonita da cidade
nesse nesse momento fértil é que a gente
começou a cultivar todo nosso trabalho
nossas vontades inspirações que nós
queremos deixar para a cidade neste
lugar é nós nós tínhamos um grupo de
amigos que começou a freqüentar e no dia
19 de agosto de 2011
nós abrimos a bicicleta é cultural
esse é um espaço onde a gente te indica
o nosso tempo ea gente acredita que a
gente consegue reunir e e amalgama essas
esses desejos de de construir
coletivamente
a gente trabalha então com alguns
pilares que também fomos descobrindo ao
longo do tempo mas eles são é ser um
centro de apoio ao ciclista urbano é ser
um espaço com uma ação cultural com uma
agenda programa é como agenda cultural
bastante recente ser um espaço que
promove o bem-estar na sociedade na
cidade e essa é um ponto de referência
no empreendedorismo da bicicleta
assim que você adentra na bicicletaria
com essa através da rampa ela a esquerda
você tem a recepção e é curioso porque
as pessoas
atualmente quando passa ali na frente
elas é não entendem muito bem tem uma
placa dizendo bicicletaria cultural mas
elas não entender bem ao certo se é uma
bicicletaria ser uma cultura e todos
entram ali falando isso aqui é mesmo uma
bicicletaria
e assim a gente explica um pouco mais
sobre o que a gente faz ali dentro
gosto muito daquela história aconteceu
anteriormente quando um grupo de
estudantes é e infantil do colégio terra
firme e eles interpretaram a patrícia
meu questionamento importante é a gente
costuma receber as escolas na secretaria
é pra trabalhar sobre cidadania e sobre
as ações que a gente faz relação à
cidade como eu falei e esse aluno e lhe
perguntou se as plantas que estavam
alocados ali na rampa se elas tinham
intenção de filtrar a poluição que vinha
do centro desse centro nervoso da da
cidade
e aí eu falei pra ele que eu tinha duas
notícias para dar a ele uma era positiva
e outra negativa perguntei qual ele
queria primeiro é negativo
então eu falei olha não essas plantas
elas não são capazes de filtrar fuligem
que vêm do centro e do transporte
coletivo e do alto tráfego de carros que
a gente tem ali na frente
ah mas eu falei a notícia boa a notícia
boa é que de fato aquelas plantas no
centro da cidade na rampa ela altera
nossa relação com o espaço ela altera a
nossa disposição com as pessoas com o
ambiente até que o nosso teto econômico
então de fato ela tem sim uma influência
e uma certa filtragem
ao entrar na secretaria nesse lugar no
centro da cidade tenha entrado no lugar
de bicicleta ali a gente recebe um
estacionamento de bicicletas abrir
cidinho sete da manhã as equipes chegam
tomam banho vão trabalhar satisfeitos e
felizes e motivados né
não precisei tomar cafezinho de manhã
para abordagem em histórias fantásticas
decidir se esse equipamento vai de
estacionamento
uma delas é de um advogado que tinha uma
caminhonete e costumava estacionar
nesses prédios estacionamento garagem
que tem uma vez que o estacionamento a o
elevador ficou e aí ele recebeu a
notícia que o carro vai ficar 40 dias
parado naquele lugar até a peça chegar
assim então não querendo pegar o ônibus
resolveu tirar a bicicleta da garagem
experimentou escreveria isso foi um
crescente onde ele começou a praticar
outros esportes ea vida dele mudou ele
está muito feliz onde nenhuma outra
história também de uma bolsa que teve a
recomendação do médico e ela falou olha
ele falou pra ela né mas você pratica
exercício você vai pra faca fazer uma
cirurgia e aí ela decidiu conhecer com
esse com esse lugar de poder estacionar
a bicicleta ela então desenvolveu uma
rotina onde ela usava o estacionamento
deixava lá e e decidiu então o neo optou
pela bicicleta pelo exercício e isso faz
um tempo já mas ultimamente a última vez
eu vi ela estava com uma outra bicicleta
que estava no trabalho
mas ela não tinha a faca ela também a
gente mantém uma oficina comunitária e
as pessoas podem usar ferramentas para
consertar a bicicleta está um ganho
muito grande na segurança dos ciclistas
às vezes uma desregulada um freio mal
colocado assim pode ser perigoso
então eles abaixo um baixo custo como é
com certo pra quem não sabe consertar a
gente dá um curso é quinzenal de
mecânica que já formou com os mecânicos
que abrir outros escritores da cidade
também é agente de serviço de baixo
preço com mecânicos ex-ceo e
colaboradores
caso a pessoa já saiba mexer em
bicicleta a gente compartilha as
ferramentas também e aí existe um
exercício inclusive de é um trabalho
colaborativo ea gestão econômica também
é colaborativa quando as pessoas
oferecem um valor que elas acham justo
pelo compartilhamento do espaço
mas tem mais coisa ainda na secretaria a
gente tem curso de equilíbrio
o curso de equilíbrio ele é uma uma
proposta para as pessoas que querem é
aprender a andar de bicicleta e quando a
gente abriu é bem no comecinho
a gente achava que atender as crianças
né do centro e porque não tinha muito
espaço pra pedalar mas não a maioria das
pessoas que vieram atraídos pelo curso
de equilíbrio são mulheres 80 por cento
são mulheres ea maioria delas têm mais
de 50 anos
elas vêm realizar o sonho de pedalar de
superar esse desafio
na maioria das vezes pai e mãe é pai e
irmão não deixavam a usar e ali elas
conseguem alcançar esse sonho
uma das coisas interessantes lá é a
efervescência pujança cultural que
acontece lá
somos um espaço de eventos onde não
somos uma casa noturna em um bar mas
conseguimos naquele porão abrigar uma
uma efervescência cultural em um cultivo
da cultura onde artistas locais é vamos
lá apresentações os seus eventos e
alguns comentam isso que o público não
conseguimos é chamar as pessoas para
assistir a gente costuma chamar esse
espaço de um cimento fértil onde as
coisas brotam você chega querendo
cantar a gente tem espaço a gente só tem
que organizar a agenda e claro a gente
faz e se essa divulgação para o público
querendo alimentar cada vez mais essa
proposta é na nessa é a agenda cultural
uma das coisas que vale a pena destacar
é a criação e realização junto com
fernando ribeiro um colega da
performance que é desde em 2012 e
realizamos uma mostra de performance em
curitiba um espaço para gerar repertório
público formar público nessa linguagem
híbrida entre artes cênicas e linguagens
visuais
então hoje em dia o peart ele é essa
estrutura dele ele tem uma periodicidade
mensal onde no mínimo dois artistas são
convidados locais dos do brasil e também
fora do brasil então atualmente nós
temos no peart nós somos o evento de
maior é o maior o evento de performance
independente no brasil
ele também é um ecossistema de
iniciativas né aí comecei a amalgamar um
grupo coletivo de pessoas com outras
iniciativas também uma delas uma galeria
de arte de sua contemporânea farol que
mantêm as posições mantêm leilões de
arte e oxigena a o mercado de arte na
cidade e em outras vezes muito
importante é a associação de ciclistas
do autor do sul
ele pretende não ser uma uma associação
com a delimitação um física é uma
limitação não é natural é a bacia do rio
iguaçu nos municípios do entorno de
curitiba que mantém lá do alto do rio
assunto é assim que passou ela faz o
braço de advocacy nesse movimento da da
bicicleta nessa cultura da bicicleta e
são várias as conquistas da 5a sul até
hoje dá pra dizer que as mais recentes é
ter é inserido duas questões nas provas
do detran de habilitação e do curso de
reciclagem também sobre bicicleta
a vantagem é um imposto estadual para
bicicletas
a substituição tributária que foi a que
conseguiu ser reduzido paraná inteiro é
outra tv um fórum mundial de bicicleta
que nos momentos mais importantes de
probabilidade
é que todas as pessoas do mundo inteiro
para curitiba para comungar bicicleta
pra ter propostas para a cidade ele foi
um marco na cidade de bicicleta para o
mundo né
é uma outra outra é a construção
coletiva que seu ajudou a fazer a ponte
com o poder público foi a criação de uma
praça uma praça de bolso do ciclista na
frente da secretaria
um lugar que foi construído pela mão das
pessoas das crianças e as pessoas
sentirão muito mais donas da cidade
assim é assim e também tem uma outra
coisa aquele movimento dos artistas que
aconteciam todos setembro acabou virando
lei então no estado do paraná
o mês de setembro então é comemorado e
oficial é mês da bicicleta onde todo o
estado deve levantar e e é todos os
órgãos e secretarias devem discutir a
mobilidade ea bicicleta mas nem sempre
foi assim é a gente teve um começo
é um começo que nós não sabemos que nós
estávamos fazendo ao saber que fazemos
coisas não sabe ao certo é o ímpeto da
ação então nomear isso entender que o
vocabulário que a gente acessava foi uma
descoberta e essa descoberta então se
deu pela primeira vez no edital da
aliança empreendedora em 2012 quando a
gente se identificou com o perfil que
eles estavam colocando as iniciativas e
lá é não nos candidatamos e fomos
selecionados e reconhecidos como
empreendedores sociais é primeiro lugar
e e o fernando ganhou uma viagem para
são paulo
mas além disso também tem outras mas foi
interessante que a gente teve no mesmo
hotel durante uma semana um treinamento
com empreendedores do brasil inteiro
pessoas que tinham bancos sociais que
eram associações de pescadores que
criava galinhas caipiras no ceará mas
todos eles tinham uma coisa muito
semelhante tinha o brilho do olho quando
falava do seu negócio é ter um impacto
muito grande nessa região de uma rede
precisava uma entender algumas questões
não é como a questão financeira é muito
importante é uma aliança fez a primeira
é a pegada nessa nessa questão sim mas a
gente continua buscando que vocabulário
era isso que a gente acessava e daí mais
uma vez encontrei um edital é do
instituto ligado na verdade o que
acontece é que até
hoje nesses cinco anos da bicicletaria
cultural os maiores investimentos que a
gente teve na nossa história foram dos
prêmios que a gente se inscreveu
então nesse segundo caso em 2014
o instituto legado oferecia
reconhecimento também pelo perfil a
gente identificou e reconhecimento como
é quais são as iniciativas que causam
maior impacto social
e nessas iniciativas queremos oferecer
então assessoria ferramentas para que
vocês saibam gerar um uma auto
referência gerar um alto conhecimento né
como se apresentar e foi de fato
bastante revolucionário a gente essas
ferramentas para avaliar quais são os
dados que a gente gera entender que além
dessas ações que acontecem no ímpeto e
diariamente o cotidiano operacional é
também uma revela também na cidade é com
a com a evasão ou com uma circulação
livre de carros no centro se a gente
permite o estacionamento de bicicletas a
evitá emitir gases poluentes entre
outras coisas e se esse prêmio mas
ganhamos junto com a associação de
ciclistas
fizemos uma candidatura unificada fomos
os vencedores ganhamos um aporte
financeiro esse treinamento mas uma
coisa muito importante é aprendermos a
realmente a melhorar as nossas nove
empatou cinco e só para ver se conseguia
escrever a gente num outro prêmio dessa
vez estava acontecendo um concurso
internacional chamado smart de 20 anos
que perguntava numa série de de etapas
seletivas perguntava então finalmente
qual é o nosso plano de negócios ea
partir dessas ferramentas é que a gente
conseguiu identificar e projetar a a
continuação da secretaria e foi então
quando nós fomos contemplados por esse
concurso e fomos então selecionados
entre os 15 melhores entre as 15
melhores ideias para coabitar o espaço
urbano
na categoria mundo
mas os desafios são muitos né
a gente tem pela frente o horizonte é
uma necessidade de comunicar mais com os
ciclistas com a população onde com
certeza esse retorno das falas
a gente tem que ampliar nosso espaço
físico para receber para melhorar o
atendimento ao ciclistas e as pessoas
querem fazer eventos é a secretaria
cultural pode ser uma colmeia ea gente
se as abelhas operacionais operárias
então a gente visualiza que existe ainda
um longo caminho pela frente mas eu
gostaria de convidar vocês pra celebrar
duas idéias para o cultivo de um corpo
social isso é legal